DR. SCOTT HOLLIER: I'm Dr. Scott Hollier.
I'm a digital access specialist.
I've worked in the corporate, government, and not-for-profit sectors
for about 15 years.
And a big part of my focus is to ensure that people with disabilities
get access to computers and internet-related technologies.
For people with disabilities, there are a lot of great benefits.
And I think one of the really helpful benefits,
particularly for people who are blind or vision impaired
and people with mobility impairment is that they're
able to engage with devices in a way that would
be tricky or cumbersome otherwise.
For example, I'm a legally blind person.
And as someone who is legally blind, it's
great that when I want to say, put on a radio station,
I don't have to go to the stereo and fiddle with the knobs
and try and read a display that my eyes don't pick up.
I can just go to a digital assistant and I can just say,
hey, Google, play SBS Chill on TuneIn or something like that,
and it will immediately play that station for me.
For someone in a wheelchair, if they can't reach buttons on the device,
then they can also give commands through their smartphone
or through a digital assistant to be able to engage with that.
We're seeing more and more products evolving now, which
are really providing great support.
And it's not too far away when we'll be able to engage,
for example, being able to send a recipe to a microwave
and the device continues to cook that meal
and also be able to tell us how it's going as it does so.
So from a disability perspective, having a lot of these benefits
will make a real and profound difference,
even in these very early days.
Being able to use sensors to adjust heating,
having medical conditions monitored, and being aware
of how that's going through the Internet of Things really
is making a big difference now.
And it's going to make an even bigger difference in the future.